y
[Música]
eeuu confía en que la otan aceptará como
miembros a finlandia y a suecia al
tiempo que washington reabrió su
embajada en kiev mientras que rusia
expulsar a diplomáticos de francia
italia y españa tenemos información
desde madrid
varios estados de la unión americana
celebraron elecciones primarias para
definir sus candidatos a las a los
comicios de medio término que tendrán
lugar en noviembre y en los que se
renovará un tercio de la cámara de
representantes y la totalidad del senado
analizamos como donald trump impacta a
los republicanos
la alianza global de salud y polución
reportó que 9 millones de personas
mueren cada año por esta causa mientras
la onu advirtió que cuatro indicadores
del cambio climático como las
concentraciones de gases de efecto
invernadero y el aumento del nivel del
mar establecieron nuevos récords
acercándonos a una catástrofe climática
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría que hará calle
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
respaldó a finlandia y a suecia para
convertirse en miembros de la otan y ha
afirmado que confía en que su solicitud
será aceptada
especialmente por turquía que ha sido el
único de los países de la alianza
militar que ha rechazado el ingreso de
las naciones nórdicas mañana maiden
recibirá de washington a su homólogo
finlandés saúl y ministro y a la primera
ministra sueca magdalena anderson para
discutir sus solicitudes a la otan otra
de las movidas diplomáticas ocurrió en
kiev y es que después de casi tres meses
de haber cerrado ahora la embajada
estadounidense en ucrania reabrió sus
puertas
mientras tanto rusia expulsó a
diplomáticos de francia italia y españa
luego de que el mes pasado varios
funcionarios rusos fueron sacados de
dichos países europeos esto en medio de
las acusaciones de occidente contra
moscú por la muerte de civiles en busca
nuestra corresponsal en madrid marina
colorado nos cuenta más
el anuncio de la expulsión de 27
integrantes del personal de la embajada
y consulado español en rusia ha llegado
durante una reunión entre el ministerio
de asuntos exteriores ruso y el
embajador de españa en moscú es la
respuesta asimétrica que en madrid
habían estado esperando desde que el 5
de abril 'españa expulsar a la misma
cantidad de diplomáticos rusos la
expulsión de entonces que afectó al 60%
de la plantilla de la embajada de la
federación rusa en la capital española
fue la materialización del rechazo a la
invasión de ucrania iniciada a finales
de febrero y sobre todo a los posibles
crímenes de guerra cometidos por el
ejército liderado por la dimar kutin en
varias ciudades ucranianas como bucha o
boro dianca el embajador de españa en
rusia no se ha visto afectado por esta
decisión respuesta de moscú ya que
españa mantuvo en su puesto al jefe de
la delegación diplomática rusa en madrid
para dejar según el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de españa jose manuel
alvar es una línea de diálogo abierta
entre ambos países el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores español ha rechazado
esta decisión de rusia que obliga a los
empleados a abandonar el país en una
semana los anuncios de moscú varios
países hostiles como los denomina el
kremlin se dan mientras finlandia y
suecia pretenden unirse a la otan un
proceso que han apoyado todos los países
integrantes del organismo excepto
turquía avanza el primer juicio por
crímenes de guerra en ucrania hoy el
soldado acusado de matar a un civil
desarmado se declaró culpable el
uniformado ruso de 21 años enfrentaría
una sentencia a cadena perpetua por
asesinato premeditado rusia dice que no
tiene información del militar en juicio
veamos más en el siguiente informe se ha
convertido en el primer rostro de los
presuntos crímenes de guerra rusos vadim
si si marín de 21 años está acusado de
matar a un hombre desarmado de 62 en la
región de schumi al noreste del país en
febrero apenas unos días después de que
comenzara la invasión él y otros cuatro
soldados supuestamente robaron un
vehículo y estaban huyendo cuando se
encontraron con el hombre y lo mataron
para evitar ser denunciados la fiscal
superior de ucrania dice que el juicio
que tiene lugar en medio del conflicto
en curso pretende entregar un mensaje
con este primer juicio estamos enviando
una señal clara de qué todos los autores
todas las personas que ordenaron o
ayudaron a cometer crímenes en ucrania
no podrán evitar su responsabilidad
también están en marcha varias
investigaciones internacionales con la
participación de la onu y la corte penal
internacional
muchas se centran en el suburbio de
busca en kiev donde se encontraron los
cadáveres de cientos de civiles tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas a
principios de abril mientras tanto los
fiscales ucranianos avanzan en la
investigación de más de 11.000 casos y
se espera que otros dos también se
desarrollen rápidamente un soldado ruso
será juzgado en ausencia por violación y
asesinato mientras que el juicio contra
dos soldados acusados de disparar
cohetes contra civiles en la región
nororiental de jarquín comenzará el
jueves y pasamos a noticias de eeuu
porque se votaron las primarias en
pensilvania que en tokío oregón carolina
del norte
hay en idaho para decidir quiénes serán
los nominados de ambos partidos de cara
a las elecciones de medio término que
tendrán lugar en noviembre para entender
cuál es el alcance de estas primarias
conectamos a esta hora con cara
escalante él es director general del
centro interamericano de gerencia
política bienvenido a france 24 gana o
pierde donald trump con estas primarias
y qué implica esto para el partido
republicano
bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación
ciertamente de las primarias que se
realizaron ayer ha dado cierta fortaleza
todavía al presidente otro no todo no
todos los candidatos designados por él
en esta en estas primarias del día de
ayer la ganó pero la mayoría y los más
significativos por lo menos el caso de
el candidato a gobernador de el estado
de pensilvania que es muy significativo
porque además apoyó a más la
movilización del 6 de enero del 20 y en
otros estados también algunos de sus
candidatos fue beneficiados por los
votos no todo no todo lo ganó pero
ciertamente indica que el presidente de
tron todavía es cierto tiene cierto
poder muy significativo y determinante
para ganar elecciones dentro del partido
republicano y continuará con ese poder
de cara a las elecciones de medio
término
todo indica que si es ciertamente el
presidente vaya in sigue en caída aunque
bueno ha bajado la velocidad de la caída
gracias indirectamente a la guerra pero
la inflación en eeuu ha crecido no para
la inflación
el mes pasado rompió el récord en los
últimos 40 años y la subida de la
gasolina la gasolina no deja de subir
permanentemente en todos los estados de
hecho en california les está pagando a 6
dólares 50 el galón
vamos estamos hablando de cifras muy muy
muy significativas para el bolsillo del
ciudadano y el ciudadano está viendo
principalmente su problema económico
problema de inflación problema de
aumento de la gasolina también hay
problemas de abastecimiento en algunos
productos todavía existe en eeuu y el
problema de empleo todavía aunque se ha
recuperado todavía le falta mucho al
país salir adelante entonces todo esto
están dando las condiciones o la
tormenta prueba
para que el presidente todo se consolide
en esta elección en medio término falta
todavía
el resto de la gestión del presidente
bailen si logran parar si hay resultados
positivos a nivel internacional si
logran resolver el problema de inflación
si logran resolver el problema de la
gasolina pudiéramos tener cambios
significativos y previamente usted
mencionó pensilvania donde se puede dar
una de las contiendas más competitivas
entre los republicanos y los demócratas
en otoño porque importa este estado
bueno porque es un estado lo que
llamamos aquí un switch facebook estado
que cambia en cada elección hay
elecciones la última elección la ganó el
presidente vaivén pero en la anterior
elección cuando todo se comiera
candidato frente a hitler y lo ganó el
trump ya era un estado que
permanentemente va cambiando su forma de
votar no es como estados permanentes
fijos como texas que un estado que
normalmente siempre votar republicano o
california nueva york que siempre votan
demócrata entonces como aquí la elección
en segundo grado está este tipo de
estados generan mucho interés a la hora
de los resultados de elecciones como
está en medio término carlos escalante
gracias por estar con nosotros
muchísimas gracias muy buenas noches
saluda tu auditorio gracias y cambiamos
de noticia porque en lo que puede leerse
como un intento por salvar la cumbre de
las américas estados unidos suavizó
varias de las sanciones que tenía contra
cuba y venezuela esto luego de que los
mandatarios de méxico bolivia y
guatemala se negaron a asistir a la
reunión que se realizará en los ángeles
todo si la casa blanca no invita a cuba
venezuela y nicaragua las invitaciones
aún no han sido enviadas oficialmente
pero ya el mandatario nicaragüense
daniel ortega respondió que no le
interesa abrir el colchón nos cuenta
a menos de tres semanas de la cumbre de
las américas que debe tener lugar en los
ángeles del 6 al 10 de junio algunas
tensiones emergieron en el continente
guatemala informó que no participará en
el evento mientras que méxico honduras y
bolivia condicionaron su presencia la
invitación de nicaragua cuba y venezuela
que en principio fueron excluidos de
ella por eeuu en la cumbre
podría
a ayudar
e iniciar una política nueva y le tengo
confianza
al presidente
baile el poder y a
[Música]
día será tras política
anacrónica de subordinación de falta de
respeto a la independencia a la
soberanía de los pueblos de los países
para aliviar las tensiones
joe biden anunció el martes el
levantamiento de algunas sanciones
económicas contra venezuela y al mismo
tiempo el gobierno de nicolás maduro y
la oposición informaron de la
reanudación de sus negociaciones para
ponerle fin a la crisis y méxico reiteró
su disposición para hacer el anfitrión
un día antes la casa blanca también
notificó de la flexibilización de
algunas de sus medidas contra cuba con
el restablecimiento de vuelos
comerciales o la reactivación del
programa de reunificación familiar
decisiones que no acaban de convencer a
la isla el bloqueo de colusión pero de
lo que corroboró somos hoy es un
componente fundamental continúa
totalmente en pie y continúa afecta con
tino afectando el desempeño de nuestra
economía en vísperas de la cumbre de las
américas la primera dama jill biden
inició una gira de seis días en américa
latina donde está previsto que visite
ecuador panamá y costa rica en américa
aumentó un 27% los nuevos contagios por
kobe 19 la semana pasada así lo reveló
la ope s en el último mes la pandemia se
ha propagado de manera constante en el
continente por lo que las
hospitalizaciones crecieron en 18 países
y centroamérica fue la región con más
casos con un 80 por ciento de incremento
ante el panorama la ope ese alerta que
la situación puede empeorar
la semana pasada nuestra región registró
más de 900 18.000 casos lo cual
representa un aumento del 27 2% en
comparación con la semana anterior se
registraron más de 3500 muestres las
hospitalizaciones por kobe 19 aumentaron
en 18 países y las admisiones a unidades
de cuidados intensivos
aumentaron en 13 países y territorios la
organización metereológica mundial
publicó un informe en el que advierte
sobre el agravamiento de la crisis
climática así lo dijo la organización en
su informe de 2021 en el que agregó que
los océanos alcanzaron máximos de
calentamiento y acidificación asimismo
señaló que los niveles de dióxido de
carbono y metano en la atmósfera
superaron los del año anterior el
reporte también acusa que los últimos
siete años han sido los más calurosos en
los que se tiene constancia también hoy
se conoció que las muertes por el aire
contaminado aumentaron un 7% entre 2015
y 2019 según un estudio de la alianza
global en salud y polución más detalles
en este informe en los cielos de las
grandes ciudades se ve la lo gris de la
polución la contaminación atmosférica
causada por las actividades humanas es
cada vez más perjudicial para la salud
según un estudio publicado en la revista
the lancet planetary health las muertes
relacionadas a la contaminación del aire
aumentaron un 7% entre 2015 y 2019 un
fenómeno que causa la muerte de 9
millones de personas al año y que sigue
estando poco identificado según los
autores del estudio
la contaminación es un factor de riesgo
de muerte como muchos otros cuando se
observa que contribuye a la
contaminación se trata principalmente de
enfermedades no transmisibles que
figuran como causa real de muerte en el
certificado de funciones casi nunca
verás la contaminación como causa de
muerte
según el estudio el 75% de estas muertes
están causadas directamente por la
contaminación atmosférica pero las
muertes por exposición a sustancias
químicas y metales pesados también han
aumentado un 66 por ciento desde el año
2000 trata de un fenómeno que afecta
principalmente a los países pobres y en
desarrollo
cuando estos países industrializados se
produce también un fenómeno de
urbanización cada vez más personas se
trasladan a las zonas donde hay
contaminación y al mismo tiempo hay un
envejecimiento de la población y todas
estas cosas se combinan y aumentan la
carga de estas poblaciones
chad la república centroafricana y
nigeria son algunos de los países que
registran la mayor tasa de mortalidad
por la contaminación atmosférica
hasta aquí las noticias sigan conectados
con france24
[Música]